hey Vsauce Michael here this is the song
of the kawaii
OOW bird in 1987 this species of bird
became extinct there are no more but
before the last living one died its song
was recorded this is that song it is the
song of an ending the final member of a
species asking to know one hey where are
we all it's a male calling for a mate
that will never come for what it's worth
the song is still here we are listening
to it now because it was recorded the
species is lost but the song isn't and
that's the heart of something really big
remember that the word record comes from
core meaning heart to record is to wreak
or to bring something back into your
heart echoes fossils bones footprints
nature's memory is only so immediate I
mean even light itself scatters is
absorbed and dense according to the
inverse-square law the universe forgets
slowly but we humans have created
special ways to preserve moments to take
them and turn them into stories things
that can be shared we recorded retold
disappear perhaps much later than they
would otherwise
I recently had the opportunity to speak
with Sir David Attenborough the mind and
voice behind so many important stories
and Natural History programs like the
very new planet Earth - from BBC earth I
even got to see an episode and of course
it's phenomenal it's also a time capsule
of sorts a gift that perhaps humans
alone on this planet can give earth a
record of itself I'd like to share our
conversation with you we covered many
things technology science communication
humans life language but let's start
with one of the most immediate effects
the program has on viewers it's a mirror
in nature in animals we see ourselves
despair love hope heroes and villains
now whether the animals themselves are
aware of these emotions or themes is
difficult to know or even investigate
but I asked Sir David Attenborough about
storytelling and the responsibilities
that come with that power this whole
program is like a night at the movies
but the characters are animals and there
haven't been scripted it makes me wonder
if you know all the things that pull at
our hearts that we write for the screen
for actors are just us replaying the
same dramas that have been around since
earth began well that's that's true life
has the same first life the emergence of
a new individual creature onto this
planet the end is in the an in-between
while those mating and there's
aggression and the so on and so these
are the eternal stories and you you
neglect or ignore their power actual
peril I mean these are the important
stories and you you do try to do them
justice them it both in fundamental
truths and profound truths and in the
trimmings
do you have advice for younger science
communicators when it comes to reaching
a large audience in acting the the
change that they want to see I don't
think I have any advice I'm still
learning and still struggling with
things and it's a very collaborative
jabu person who starts giving handing
out advice people know that know what
they're after
Barnard's if they're any good in the
business they know what they're after
and then they want to do and in any case
the advice I give it's bound to be about
yesterday's technology or yesterday's
way of doing things and tomorrow is what
we're on about and and it's it's young
people today who are using the new
technology in ways that I can't dream of
so I wouldn't give advice to people I
mean people talk about going to learn to
make documentary films and and I say
don't come to me ivan is yesterday's
equipment you've got to be using
tomorrow's equipment and you'll do it in
your and that equipment well if you're
true to it will dictate the way in which
you deal with it and what you handle
these things and that's the way you get
advanced is in whatever technology or
deed whatever art we're talking about
technology is a big part of planet Earth
- we can document record track and film
animals now like never before in the ten
years since the first planet Earth
drones have become smaller and quieter
we have learned how to better find and
study and predict animal behavior planet
Earth - captured things that we science
had not yet seen happen and in some
cases didn't even know did happen I just
was really struck today by the landmark
nature of the program that's why I think
it's so important I think that we're
documenting things that 50 years ago no
one even had seen and I think we have a
responsibility for better or worse to
document these things
for ourselves for others and for the
future I think we have a very fortunate
time living and very fortunate
technologies enable us to do things and
we ought to use it with some sense of
responsibility for the next generation
and it is absolutely the case that a
demonstrable species are disappearing
and it's quite possible the things that
I filmed 20 years ago in 30 years time
will not be exist so we have that as a
responsibility I mean what would we not
give to be able to see a but I Tanis or
our dinosaur hunting people had been
around that - the time scale is
different silly better to say mammoths
it would be great to see a mammoths
would it not or even a dodo bird I'd
like yeah I wouldn't mind seeing a dead
okay we have photographs of them were
just I thinking no no no no no yes we
don't even have a complete genuine
individual body really no the last
complete one was a specimen in Oxford
Museum and in the middle of the early
nineteenth century developed maggots and
so on so they burnt it but they've then
some chap pulled out one or two of the
bones but now you have you have you can
put together and enough bones from
different individuals to have a complete
dodo skeleton so you know who the shape
of every bone but then you don't have
the individual and even the ones you see
in museums no one nearly all was made of
sort of chicken feathers and suitably
dyed and painted with a plaster head the
camera can now capture things that
nature and ourselves previously
struggled to keep with such detail like
the dodo bird which went extinct in the
1600s it's easy to feel sad that such
creatures are lost that we can't pet
them today or that there wasn't a planet
Earth program back then to at least film
them but speaking of that emotion
feeling hope and pity at the
helplessness of an animal in the wild
being hunted as prey struggling to get
back on land to feed its children
like these chinstrap penguins should we
do more than record them I mean in cases
like this ought we intervene and give
them a helping hand when it comes to
interfering mm-hmm
where would you draw the line what if I
wanted to like help the chinstrap
penguins get onto the land
yeah is that a good way to interfere or
even then should I let them grow it
their own ways I mean if you if if you
see if you're filming a little Impala
for a little antelope form hiding in the
grass
freezing still refusing to move and
you'll see a cheetah it's talking it was
it and you've been filming this little
pond fawn because you've been its
relationship with its mother so you
weren't seeing it suckling and so on and
the temptation there you can see this
cheetah getting closer to lean out of
the land robe and say shoot you know and
know if you did that certainly the form
would run and would be actually
terrified out of its wits and run
probably so far I wouldn't be able to
find its way back the cheetah would have
lost its prey wouldn't been able to
catch up with it
and so the cheetah would go back and and
have to find another Impala for the
first Impala for will probably not get
back and we knocked off by something
else because it's away from its home
territory so what you've done is
actually make things worse I also asked
about humans where is the planet Earth
episode about people he said this your
own species is a different kettle of
fish
it's why you can't make a natural
history series about Homo sapiens that's
any good because I ran I once wrote one
I once started to write a series well
why don't we look at human beings just
as though they are animals we'll fill
them in the same way as you would film
monkeys or elephants or whatever
but then at the penny dropped you can't
make a series about any animal how human
or anything else unless you deal with
sexuality and courtship so suddenly you
find that you are actually a peeping tom
that you're going to you're gonna film
people in courtship without ten 'i'm
impossible you can do that with animals
yeah yes you do but that's the point you
can't do that for animals because we are
not animals and not animals in that
sense we are animals in other senses but
we can't do it to our own species in my
view right how are we different the
closer we look for differences
distinctions hard-and-fast discrete
separations the more blur we see we
aren't the only things that use tools
that play that communicate that have
social structure the differences we hope
to find often turn out to be issues not
of unprecedented features but of matters
of degree even language now appears not
to be a sudden invention or gift but
rather a property that emerged from a
happy accident of more primitive
features we happen to be in the right
place to inherit Sir David Attenborough
and I spoke about distinctions and words
when I asked about life what would you
say defines life and defines defined
humors yeah life what is the difference
between the particles their living and
dead yeah
don't know because you can't simply say
it's it's it's reproduction because the
little bubbles reproduce you know it's
funny that that line is so hard to
define when we spend our whole lives
alive yeah and that's why when you're
dealing with it with questions about
well how did life start you say well I
can't tell you how excited exactly but I
can tell you where it starts and all the
sorts of things that that began and they
were things like complex molecules which
we've got a membrane around the
and eventually before you knew where
they were they were policies but when
that magic moment comes that extraordin
my we still don't understand I like that
I hadn't really thought of this before
but yeah dead and alive or concepts we
came up with I once tried to ask someone
who was an expert is a hyena a cat or a
dog and he just refused to answer he
said we make up these categories
absolutely right I mean we have this
passion to classify and that's the basic
answer because the only way you can hunt
handle very very complex something's you
have to start pacify in order to be able
to get into a handle of all bits but
that's a human concept that's what we've
done we have to decide that that that's
a captain that's a dog because those are
the two things that we started off with
but then as you explore the world you
would discover that there are things
that are neither harder and you can then
eventually if you're clever enough and
lucky enough to find the specimens you
can form a phylogenetic tree and you can
see in the spread then the time when at
the base of roof there's a thing that
which is that what you might call a cog
or a bag or a cat or whatever I mean
which is neither one or the other that's
the way it is and then they've out
diversified and then slowly became
things but but it's a it's a human
construct what do you want people to
take away from planet Earth - as opposed
to planet Earth one or other programs
you've worked on the reality and the
importance of the world the recognition
that we aren't the only species that
inhabited the recognition that in moral
terms we can't assume that everything is
ours for to do with exactly how we wish
and that other creatures on the earth
also have places in the in the grand
scheme of things
and then actually we are part of that
and then if we damage them in the end
read Amager selves why is it important
for us to record and document to give
ourselves the perspective of ourselves
on our own futures and iron past our
planet is amazing nature preserves
itself as best it can but the hill it
rolls down natural selection isn't about
preserving the past it's about survival
we however can tell stories about things
describe them record them measure them
with more detail and voice than any
other living or nonliving thing even if
a story is just made up it's still an
attempt to articulate encapsulate and
preserve something a thought and idea
that otherwise would be forgotten I
don't know if this ability makes humans
different from other animals but it does
in a way mean that we are our planet's
autobiographer 'he's the part of it that
documents and records and tells about it
so let's tell as many stories as
possible and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
you